I fam its Monte Carlo
welcome to Ramsey redemption if it's
your first time hanging out with us
that's because this is our very first
video welcome so here's a deal Gordon
Ramsay has lots of opinions especially
when it comes to food and any time you
send him a picture of your food on
Twitter and he thinks it's borderline
crazypants
he is gonna burn you I'm here to redeem
your dishes let's see what the big man
has to say about this week's dish this
steak has died that's what happened here
what is that next to the steak there's
the most wilted look at it looks like my
hopes and dreams make a fabulous stake
for our ramsay redemption let's do this
we're gonna start with a fabulous ribeye
steak now why do we love the ribeye if
you have a tendency to burn your steaks
you need a little forgiveness in your
life here's an awesome trick if you want
to create an amazing crust you have to
dry off your steak all right now that
it's nice and dry we're gonna salt it
with kosher salt the flakes on kosher
salt or a lot bigger and you're going to
use more salt than you think you need it
needs to be coated on all sides you
ready see that okay now we're going to
make this steak Porto Rican you know how
you know you're dealing with a Puerto
Rican they won't shut up about it like
me in Puerto Rico we have a great spice
blend it's called global if you want a
recipe for a Lobel I've got it for you
in the description below check it out
now we're gonna let this steak rest
overnight in the fridge why the salt
that we just poured on it is going to
dry brine
steak that's just a fancy way of saying
it's gonna suck out all the juices and
the state's gonna be like give it back
and all that flavor is gonna be inside
and amazing so you can leave it
uncovered we'll put that in right now
and leave it in for at least an hour but
preferably overnight let your steak rest
for at least a half an hour so it comes
up to room temperature and then put your
salts and your spices on it just before
it hits the pan let's talk about our pan
you have to get it smoking hot
I want you to check out what water does
I love it science we're gonna add some
pepper to it olive oil
cover that pan in oil and then put your
stake in away from you see that battle
right now we're creating an incredible
fear you won't be able to move the steak
until the proteins release the steak
from the pan that's how you know that
sear has started
yes that looks great
Beauty it's tender like a love song what
I'm doing now is searing the fat that's
so important to do
nobody likes a jig roast uncooked piece
of gristle sometimes I'd like to pretend
that's my ex-husband face danger if
you're watching mommy's totally kidding
that is almost ready to go we're gonna
add a couple moms of butter and butter
base our garlic the trick the babe
things is to tip the pan we're not
burning the steak does that mean you're
cooking it all right
you could rest this pig on a plate why
I'm just gonna ruin that crust but
you've been working on instead
rest it on a sheet pan
oh yeah
I'm so serious nobody's touching this
all right we're gonna take this garlic
out cuz it's gonna burn it's given its
life up breast thank you garlic thank
you
all these pan juices we're gonna keep up
not all of them about two tablespoons
worth it's all the flavor is B stay in
Cebu Davao is Spanish for steak with
onions so here we have a bunch of onions
we're gonna add the onions to our pan a
little saltiness that salt is gonna help
sweat the liquid out of the onions see
that all that seems well these onions
are going off we are gonna mince some
garlic but when you're mincing it has a
tendency to stick and it can be a little
bit of a pain but what you're going to
do is grab some salt put it over and
that's gonna help the chop we're gonna
want to mince it into almost into a
paste okay put your palm on the night
and press it forward and away from you
not told you to do it towards you're
gonna get cut and then you gonna blame
you're gonna write me a bunch of crazy
nonsense on Twitter and then please
don't use the sharp end of your knife to
scrape that ruins your night you can use
the back of the knife and we are gonna
add it to our onions why do we not add
the garlic right away when we add the
onion because garlic is like our very
some for the best friends okay it gets
burnt real fast
as soon as you start smelling that
garlic bloom we are going to add our
vinegar and a chicken stock to create a
pan sauce this is apple cider vinegar
you can use white still vinegar that's a
traditional import or you go alright why
are we making a pan sauce because we're
elevating a dish okay Gordon Ramsay has
to sign off on this and say it has been
redeemed we're gonna just go ahead and
let this garlic and onion mixture cook
down you're gonna want it to reduce by
half that sauce is going to thicken
considerably with the help of our friend
butter new Dias we are going to cut the
steak after its rested so the juices
don't blow out of it you want juicy
beautiful steaks now we're gonna cut at
an angle that is another way to create
tenderness because we're cutting the
muscle fibers teeny-tiny and short and
at an angle angle your knife to see how
I'm holding it at an angle do that
it's beautiful
it is time to plate we're gonna plate it
with rice and beans as is traditional in
Puerto Rico it is already looking so
much better
cover it with our beautiful amazing
onion
now I'm gonna garnish it because you
need a little bit okay you can pick
cilantro leaf by leaf or you can be
smart about it and just use a fork to
get all paying homage to the last dish
Stephanie your face was more burnt and
Kanye after he didn't let Taylor finish
mine is cooked to perfection this dish
has been redeemed you better say it he's
gonna say it right let's see what Gordon
thinks someone needs to eat this dish we
all have dishes that need redemption
take a picture of yours or a video and
to us with the hashtag Ramsey Redemption
won't fix it
thanks for hanging out make sure to hit
subscribe Gordon means like 11 million
more followers show off to hot are all
the alarms gonna go off that would be so
amazing